[Música]
al menos 150.000 ucranianos están
huyendo de su país según la onu la
mayoría cruza hacia naciones vecinas
como polonia eslovaquia aburrir a casi
todos sus mujeres y niños pues los
hombres ucranianos fueron llamados al
combate
rusia tiene casi tres veces más de
soldados que ucrania según el instituto
internacional de estudios estratégicos
en esta misión analizaremos la capacidad
militar de ambos países en medio del
conflicto
y mientras tanto en diferentes partes de
américa latina' salieron cientos de
manifestantes a rechazar la ofensiva
militar rusa hubo desde llamados de paz
hasta insultos al presidente ruso
vladimir putin
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los acompaña maría clara calle y es un
placer estar con ustedes y comenzamos
esta emisión en ucrania un
almacenamiento de petróleo quedó en
llamas al suroeste de kiev y es que en
la ciudad de valls y ccoo impactaron
misiles rusos según dijo la alcaldesa
además en harkov la segunda ciudad más
grande de ucrania explotó una tubería de
gas natural según afirmó la oficina de
la presidencia el domingo en la
madrugada hora local también se
escucharon al menos dos detonaciones en
kiev esta última ciudad se encuentra
bajo un toque de queda hasta el próximo
lunes a medida que las tropas rusas se
acercan
150 mil refugiados la onu estima que
esta cantidad de personas salieron de
ucrania para llegar a otros países la
mayoría busca asilo en polonia
eslovaquia y rumanía entre otras
naciones la guerra ha obligado incluso
al personal extranjero de la
organización para la seguridad y la
cooperación en europa a huir del país
arianna villacorta nostra de todos los
detalles
con lágrimas en los ojos cientos de
miles de ucranianos huyen de su país de
día de noche a pie en tren o en carro en
la medida que las fuerzas rusas lanzan
ataques coordinados con misiles de
crucero y artillería sobre kiev y otras
ciudades
esta acción futura
éramos absolutamente libres y vivíamos
como queríamos hasta que interfirieron
horriblemente en nuestras vidas matan a
los civiles y bombardean las casas de
los civiles con cohetes
las familias aspiran a entrar en polonia
eslovaquia rumanía hungría y moldavia
mientras tanto se refugian en pabellones
deportivos y estaciones de tren donde
reciben abrigo alimentos y en algunos
casos juguetes a veces desechó
obviamente la situación es
extremadamente fluida vemos los números
y la situación cambiar minuto a minuto
rain agua pero en este momento lo que
podemos confirmar es que al menos
150.000 personas han huido de ahora son
refugiados fuera de ucrania train we
know that & bistró sabemos que al menos
100.000 pero probablemente un número
mucho mayor ya se han desplazado
internamente dentro de ucrania crane las
normas ucranianas impiden que los
hombres de entre 18 y 60 años que puedan
ser llamados al combate crucen las
fronteras las agencias de ayuda de la
onu afirman que la guerra podría llevar
hasta 5 millones de ucranianos entre los
más de 44 millones de habitantes a huir
al extranjero con hasta 3 millones
dirigiéndose solo a polonia una de las
líneas directas de información que tiene
sobre la invasión rusa a ucrania son los
mensajes que publica el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski a través de
sus redes sociales y de los canales
oficiales mucho se discute sobre las
aptitudes del mandatario y ex actor ante
las cámaras le han hecho obtener el
respeto de su pueblo y de sus fuerzas
armadas rafael pérez nos trae la
historia
de humorista pasó a ser presidente de
ucrania mientras dure la invasión es el
comandante en jefe de un ejército que se
enfrenta a rusia una de sus principales
armas es su cuenta de instagram
convertida en un medio de contacto
directo con su pueblo y el mundo su
estrategia mensajes oportunos y frases
de impacto que han sido replicadas por
los principales medios de prensa
internacionales para hacer contrapeso al
potencial de su enemigo
buenos días ucranianos ha aparecido
mucha información falsa en internet
como si hubiese llamado a deponer las
armas y existiese algún plan de
evacuación la situación es la siguiente
yo estoy aquí
no vamos a deponer las armas
defenderemos nuestro país porque
nuestras armas son nuestra verdad
a través de las redes sociales intenta
disipar el temor que genera el avance de
las tropas rusas con su presencia en las
calles
el presidente está aquí nuestras tropas
están aquí los ciudadanos están aquí
todos nosotros estamos aquí protegiendo
la independencia de nuestro país y
seguirá siendo así también ha sabido
mostrar al mundo desde un podio
institucional todo el peso y la
responsabilidad del cargo que ostenta
me gustaría dirigirme al presidente ruso
nuevamente la lucha está ocurriendo en
todo el territorio de ucrania
sentémonos a conversar para poner fin a
la muerte de personas
muchos le aplauden su habilidad para
transmitir frente a las cámaras otros
prefieren criticar sus aptitudes
mediáticas y su carrera actoral en la
que interpretaba a un profesor
convertido en presidente de su país lo
cierto es que ha puesto sobre la mesa
una narrativa la invasión rusa y su
indiscutible liderazgo militar ante una
constante amenaza de invasión de este
caso me el cargo por su parte una de las
ventajas de rusia en el ataque contra
ucrania es que sus fuerzas superan por
mucho la capacidad militar que tiene
kiev según el instituto internacional de
estudios estratégicos el número de
militares rusos es mucho mayor al que
tiene ucrania pues casi que triplica la
cantidad de activos y reservas que tiene
los ucranianos además moscú tiene casi
cuatro veces más artillería remolcada
que kiev mientras la cantidad de
aeronaves y de helicópteros de ataque
son más de diez veces superior
previamente desde miami manuel super vio
coronel retirado del ejército de eeuu y
asesor jurídico de las fuerzas aliadas
en afganistán nos explicó si ucrania
realmente puede hacerle frente a la
arremetida rusa ante este desbalance
militar
bueno en términos de las fuerzas
militares no solamente son los números
pero que también que las fuerzas rusas
desde el año 2008 se han estado morder
modernizándose mientras que las de
ucrania son las que quedaban después de
cuando la unión soviética en otras
palabras de los 1980 así que es mucho
más
separado la capacidad de ello eso va a
ser que va a ser muy difícil para
mantener
para la defensa de los ucranios pero
pero por otra parte si me permite hay
otro en balance en esto que es el moral
de las fuerzas y por lo que hemos visto
en estos primeros tres días es que el
moral de las de las fuerzas de ucrania
superan a las de rusia en el sentido de
que todos quieren pelear y defender su
patria mientras que muchos de los rusos
soldados no entienden el por qué están
ahí nuestro invitado también nos precisó
porque las tropas ucranianas luchan con
más moral que las rusas
bueno es un poco complicado pero así en
términos simples están defendiendo a su
patria tan dependiendo a su familia a su
casa a su cultura que el señor putin
hable de que no existe una ucrania que
simplemente siempre es parte de rusia
siempre ha sido eso le da un moral muy
fuerte a los ucranios y por otra parte
para los soldados rusos para qué estamos
aquí si estos son nuestros primos y
mientras en ucrania avanza el despliegue
de tropas rusas en diferentes partes de
américa latina hubo protestas para
rechazar los ataques de moscú ucranianos
protestando en frente de la embajada de
rusia en bogotá varios de los
manifestantes sostuvieron una bandera de
ucrania en la capital colombiana en el
plantón se oponían a la invasión de su
país y a lo que llamaron la guerra
en chile quienes protestaron llevaron
pancartas en inglés ruso y en español en
una de ellas compararon al presidente
ruso vladimir putin con adolf hitler el
líder del nazismo estas manifestaciones
que ustedes ven en pantalla ocurrieron
frente a la embajada rusa en santiago el
llamado a los manifestantes fue a cesar
la guerra en el país de europa del este
novias vestidas de blanco con lágrimas
pintadas de rojo y letreros escritos en
sus cuerpos para rechazar a putin
las imágenes se vieron en ciudad de
mexico ellas dicen que es la manera de
expresar que están cansadas de los ochos
años de guerra en ucrania en referencia
al tiempo que ha pasado desde las
protestas de 2014 las manifestaciones
ocurrieron en frente de la sede
diplomática que rusia tiene en mexico
y paraguay las manifestaciones fueron en
la ciudad de encarnación los asistentes
afirmaron que el país suramericano tiene
una importante comunidad de inmigrantes
ucranianos desde allí pidieron la paz en
europa del este- y rechazaron los
operativos ordenados por vladimir putin
esa fue otra de las manifestaciones que
hubo en la región en solidaridad con
ucrania
y así llegamos al final de las noticias
los invitamos a que sigan conectados con
france24 para más información de la
actualidad internacional
[Música]